labor secretary Alex Acosta says he will
not resign over his role in Jeffrey
Epstein's child sex abuse case Acosta
spoke to reporters yesterday and
defended his controversial plea deal
with the financier in 2008 Epstein
served 13 months in jail and registered
as a sex offender after he was accused
of abusing more than two dozen underage
teenagers Ben Tracy is at the White
House Ben why did it cost to hold this
news conference in the first place well
we've learned that President Trump
called Acosta on Tuesday and urged him
to defend himself publicly now that's
the same day that President defended
Acosta basically saying that sometimes
judges and prosecutors look back and
wish they had done things differently in
hindsight but Acosta says he did nothing
wrong we did what we did because we
wanted to see Epstein
go to jail labor secretary Alex Acosta
says his only choice when he was a US
Attorney was to either prosecute Jeffrey
Epstein at trial or offer a plea deal
that guaranteed at least some jail time
how do you weigh those two if going to
trial is viewed as the roll of a dice
Acosta blamed Florida state officials
who he said were not eager to prosecute
and said Epstein would not have served
any jail time if not for him but former
Palm Beach State Attorney Barry Krisher
said in a statement Wednesday night that
Mr Acosta's recollection is completely
wrong he said if mr. Acosta was truly
concerned with the state's case and felt
he had to rescue the matter he would
have moved forward with the 53 page
indictment that his own office drafted
since Epstein pleaded not guilty to new
federal charges of sex trafficking
dozens of underage girls more women have
come forward this week saying Epstein
abused them
Jennifer arroz told NBC News she was 15
when she was assaulted by Epstein in the
early 2000s he say
forcefully raped me what hurts even more
is though is that if I wasn't afraid to
come forward sooner than maybe he would
have done it to other girls arose plans
to file a civil suit against Epstein on
Wednesday Acosta expressed sympathy for
the victims but repeatedly refused to
apologize you've got the best deal you
could get and you have no regrets
we believe that we proceeded
appropriately look no regrets is a very
hard question as you watch these victim
interviews it's very obvious that the
victims feel that this was not a
sufficient outcome many Democrats are
still calling on a constant to resign in
part because as Labor Secretary he's in
charge of combating human trafficking of
course President Trump is really the
only one who can decide his fate and at
his news conference Acosta says they
still have a great relationship Tony all
right Ben thank you very much